Satanism overt Satanism is on the rise
if you go to the Illinois state capitol
right now
you know it's it's Advent we're
preparing for Christmas time
we we look around we see Christmas trees
in the Public Square well if you go to
the Illinois State Capitol
you will see a crash the nativity scene
you will see a menorah
which you know Hanukkah is a minor feast
day it's not it's a it's not a major
Jewish holiday and and so not to to
equate Hanukkah with Christmas on as a
matter of importance for the respective
religions I think is a little silly
anyway but okay you see the menorah most
people don't have a problem with Menorah
and then the third thing you will see is
a Satanist display it's a serpent
with little apples on top of a
leather-bound copy of Nicholas
copernicus's uh on the revolution of the
celestial spheres which is especially
strange because Copernicus was a
Catholic Canon and and possibly a
Catholic priest so I the satanists as
you might expect are kind of confused
with what they're doing but uh at the
center of it you've got this this
Serpent and it's there because the
satanists are claiming that if the
Christians get their nativity scene and
the Jews get their Menara then the
satanists
have the right as a matter of religious
freedom to put up a serpent at Christmas
time and the thing is most people know
that this is wrong and we should not be
expected to tolerate this
but very few people including
conservatives very few people can
explain exactly why the satanists have
no right to a serpent at the Illinois
state capitol at Christmas time do not
be distracted by parties and presents
this Christmas season instead join
Hallows most anticipated prayer
challenge of the Year pray 25. hallow is
the number one Christian Prayer app in
the U.S and the number one Catholic app
in the world hello features over five
thousand prayers and meditations
including the rosary with Bishop Baron
and Mark Wahlberg the Bible in a year
with father Mike Schmitz and Bible
bedtime stories with Jonathan Rooney
hallow helps make prayer a priority this
Christmas with pray 25 you can do the
same for you led by cast members from
The Chosen the largest Christian
streaming Series in history pray 25 will
guide you through meditation and prayer
for 25 days leading up to Christmas pray
25 will help grow your understanding of
mankind and develop a disciplined prayer
habit during a season when discipline is
put to the test find peace and fortify
your faith this Christmas with hallow
download the app for free and join the
pray 25 challenge go to hallow.com
Michael Knowles get three months
completely free
I absolutely adore this app hello.com
Michael Knowles to reclaim your peace
during this Christmas season
the satanists have no right as a matter
of religious freedom
to put up a serpent display at the
Illinois state capitol they have no
right to engage in their public Antics
anywhere as a matter of fact
I made this point over the weekend on
social media
and the libs went crazy and the squishes
went crazy and even a number of
conservatives asked Michael come aren't
you abandoning the First Amendment
doesn't the First Amendment and the
right to Religious Freedom protect the
satanists from there no it doesn't
of course it doesn't as a matter of
History it obviously doesn't
we had established churches throughout
this country the First Amendment did not
prohibit established churches at the
state level
until well into American history because
of
certain
legal and judicial
errors in interpretation and Implement
implementation of certain laws but
furthermore we had blasphemy laws on the
books
for for a lot of American history
you could be punished by the state if
you blasphemed God
so obviously it was not the view of the
founding fathers or the framers of the
Constitution or most of the Great Men
Who Built our country that the First
Amendment or the Constitution protects
the sacred right of satanists or
anything like that in fact
the very notion of religious freedom
precludes protections for satanists the
reason is that religion is not just
anything you believe about anything I
know colloquially that's how we refer to
religion that's not what religion is
religion has a real definition okay
the religion is the moral virtue by
which a person is disposed to render to
God the service and worship that God
deserves that's what religion is
okay religion is a kind of a Justice
it through which and by which we give
God what God deserves
so it's not just any belief you have
about anything and so in this country we
have a tradition of religious freedom
which means that we are relatively quite
tolerant about how people worship and
serve God we might think that one
religious group is not worshiping God in
quite the right way you know the the
episcopalians might say those methodists
they are not rendering service and
worship to God as they ought but we have
a broad kind of Toleration
for for the different groups who
sincerely think that they're worshiping
God in the way that that he deserves
even if they're a little bit wrong about
it
satanists do not do that they singularly
do not do that they hate God
or they deny God's existence
and there's not it's a little bit of a
blurry line between those two things but
whatever satanists believe
they certainly do not believe that they
are worshiping God and serving God
whatever satanists believe either their
edgy online atheists or they are
explicitly worshiping the prince of lies
that the chief Rebel and first rebel
against God's plan either way they can't
have religious freedom because they're
not religious they're irreligious and
religion and irreligion are not the same
thing we have become even the
conservatives have become so
relativistic in recent years
well this actually is at the heart of
that argument over drag queen Story Hour
when David French who was a sort of
conservative writer now he's a liberal
writer for the Atlantic David French
came out and he said drag queen Story
Hour is a Blessing of Liberty and if we
ban drag queen Story Hour from public
spaces while by golly the libs might ban
church services I don't know Christian
Services from public spaces so who's to
say one man's drag queen story hours
another man's preaching of the Gospel no
of course not they're not the same thing
they're different things and if you
can't discern between those two things
then you don't have any faculties of
reason you can't govern yourself
no religion and irreligion are not the
same thing and this is not just some
crazy far-right Theocratic view this was
commonly understood by everybody in the
country certainly by the people who
framed the Constitution certainly by the
people who built our country until like
five minutes ago okay it's it's not a
fringe view to say no the satanists
don't ever write to to put up serpents
and statues of demons in public spaces
there is a reason that that hasn't
happened in American history until very
recently and it's because
the the Liberals have become more
radical and the conservatives have
failed to conserve a damn thing okay and
we and now we we can't even articulate
what the Constitution actually says we
don't even know we ourselves we even we
the conservatives don't really know what
religious freedom means anymore
I promise you guys it does not mean
putting up statues of demons and
serpents in state capitals okay that is
not that is not it when you are doing
that and when you were pretending that
that is some sacred right uh enshrined
in our political order you have lost the
plot
the rest of the show continues now it is
music Monday
my producers have they promised me a a
song that requires my uh
hip-hop pop music media Mogul
perspective you know I mean I'm Wonder
Mike I've come to say hello to the black
the white the red and around the purple
and yellow but first we've got to head
on over to the member block if you are
not a member click the link in the
description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]